so hi
everyone i think we should start uh
our session since it's 2 20. i'm here
with my colleague
at trevor with the business development
manager and strategic manager at
persivei
myself christian also i'm the ceo and
co-founder
of proceed ai so thank you very much
all of you to attend this this round
table
the topic of the drawing table is
improving treatment efficacy
and de-risking clinical trial with
precision medicine
so i'm going to try to cover some of the
basis and
a little bit what are our approach uh
regarding that topic
and after that we will try to have an
open discussion where you will be able
to
raise your hand and we'll give you the
uh uh
the the the authorization to basically
ask your questions or
give your inputs on various questions
thank you
so patients are very diverse and
diseases are very complex
and that leads unfortunately to a lot of
eternity
in the disease trajectory and in the
treatment response of those patients
and that heterogeneity will have a lot
of
causes or problems downstream so you
will have a patient variability
that will lead to the researcher
applying or
evaluating a drug on the wrong patient
so on top of all the inclusion exclusion
criteria that you will find in a normal
clinical trial
unfortunately you will end up with a
population that is still
very diverse and heterogeneous and that
will lead to a poor patient selection
basically in the trial
that will cause many downstream effects
so you will have high failure rates
of those trials due to that a massive
cost of those trials especially in late
phase trials
long trial duration normal trials
especially the late phase ones
can go up to five to seven years and
low treatment advocacy and poor patient
outcome once those drugs
are in the clinic or are approved and
therefore used on these very terrigens
population
so the basic concept of precision
medicine
is to treat the right is to use the
right treatment for the right patient
at the right time and this is a
fundamental concept that is not new
but it took a lot of time to start to
see
emerging solutions that do apply that
and makes it a reality either in the
clinical trial side or on the clinical
side
so um prognostic and predictive
enrichment strategy
are fundamental tools for enhancing
clinical trials and embracing precision
medicine
there are two main layers for predicting
health outcome
so the first one is prognostic
enrichment basically
this is a selecting patient with a
greater likelihood of having a disease
related
event so basically you want to identify
individuals that will have an event or
that will progress in their disease
during the duration of the trial any
subjects that will not display those
those properties will unfortunately not
be suitable to demonstrate that your
drug that you're trying to
apply to those patients will be
effective
the second layer is predictive
enrichment
so the definition of predictive
enrichment is to select patients who are
more likely to respond to an
intervention trait
an intervention drug so in this case you
want to
further refine your your selection once
you have some data on
the people that have been treated with
the drug you want to try to identify
what are the characteristics that define
those individuals that will have a
positive response and
on the reverse you can also identify
individuals that will have an adverse
event or
that will just not respond to that
specific drug
and therefore you have a framework to
really identify
most more suitable population
for treatment so that has a lot of
impacts basically that will come with
these types of enrichment strategies so
you can you can basically prevent
endpoint failure in clinical trials
lowering the cost of bringing new drugs
to the market by reducing either the
duration of the trial
or the sample size needed to demonstrate
that your drug
is effective reducing the time spent on
clinical trial recruitment by having
a more automated way to identify those
those individuals that will have the the
right profile
and finally improving treatment efficacy
um
by adding a more subgroup of individuals
that have been
targeted and well-defined to be
responding to that specific treatment
health outcome prediction requires a
more complete
understanding of the patient a broader
view of exactly what characterized that
patient and that comes with
the use of multiple modality to
characterize those individuals
so it can be imaging genetic
clinical work up blood tests
to really have a full view of the
individual and
therefore being able to uh to predict is
this future evolution
obviously multimodal data is extremely
complex
some of it are structured data others
are unstructured data
and this is very difficult for a human
to really make sense and wrap his head
around
all that data although that said it's a
very
well suited work for a machine learning
or deep learning
solutions and it's really made to
actually ingest these types of data and
make sense of that
plurality of features
so here i'm going to show some of the
one of the applications that we
we do at perceive it's in alzheimer's
disease
so alzheimer's disease has a very long
history of failure
in clinical trials in the past 20 years
we had 99.6
of clinical trials that did fail
unfortunately
for various reasons among which the
variability of the patient recruited you
still have with the inclusion exclusion
criteria
a large proportion of individuals that
do not decline cognitively during the
duration of the trial
which is uh very important point
individuals need to decline cognitively
during the duration of the trial to
demonstrate that your drug is actually
slowing down or stopping
that decline so what we've done is to
devise an enrichment tool for cognitive
decline so we target individuals at
baseline and we try to
identify as the one that will be at
higher risk and lower risk
of cognitive decline so from that
derivatives population
using our foresight platform that
combines multiple modalities
we are able to identify as a group of
individuals that will
be or remain stable for for a few years
and therefore we can
enrich the population with a with
individuals that will actually have
a more drastic effect and more drastic
effective decline
so that has multiple impacts among which
we've been able to demonstrate that
we can reduce the duration of the trial
so c significant changes
instead of three years but two years
in the trial and also reduce the
the sample size of that trial by percent
so
you recruit you need less individuals to
demonstrate
uh the same effect
so this is just a basic overview and i
would like to
uh open it to questions and discussion
on
enrichment strategy and maybe give the
the mic to uh to trevor so that he can
relay either your questions or if you
want to
to ask your question orally and you can
raise your end and it will give you
the rights to speak thank you very much
great thank you so much christian um so
i see
many people joined us part of the way
through so just a quick recap we are
perceived ai we are an
ai driven precision medicine company
accelerated
clinical research and so the goal here
is to have an interactive discussion and
so just raise your hand or type your
question the q
a and uh we're more than happy to
have it back and forth so just to kick
things off
christian one question that i had was
how can a better understanding of
patient heterogeneity help
researchers in medical fields
so basically the one of the things that
is
so i've presented more application in
their clinical trial
uh setup but obviously those tools once
you have a better characterization of
individuals that will be at higher risk
or that will respond better to treatment
can definitely be a
super useful tool uh in the clinic for a
physician either to
better manage their patient their visits
like if you know that
individuals will decline cognitively in
the near future compared to somebody
that will remain stable for
that's in the next two years it's a very
useful tool to
to manage when you will set up your next
visit
or to provide adequate care to that
individuals if he needs more
more support or specific facilities
that could be extremely useful and also
just to
take a better decision on which
drug are potentially the most effective
for that specific patient
very interesting thank you so much um so
here's another question
so uh building from what doctor
let me just check try to do both at the
same time
sorry about that
all right um
so we have a question from
[Music]
samuel um
wouldn't these tools introduce selection
bias into the treated population
therefore
only work for narrow indications trial
can you repeat the question sure so
samuel says
wouldn't these tools introduce selection
bias into the treated population
therefore only work for narrow
indications
trial so uh obviously like you you
narrow down a little bit the um
the the population that will be treated
uh that said for
uh indication like very complex
indications like alzheimer's disease or
cardiovascular where he has like a
a very large spectrum of individual that
will have like very different behavior
um for the moment it's better to have
a more clearer well-defined
group of population that do respond well
to the treatment and then expand from
that
to a larger population for the moment
what is clear is that basically trying
to do the one size fit all
doesn't work in these types of complex
disease
so we need to be a little bit more
clever and pinpoint some groups of
individuals that
uh do have the the correct properties
and the
right pressure is to for treatment and
just to add to that also
um having a better understanding of the
patients treated
is in general a very good thing and
allows for more personalized treatment
plans
going down the road um so thank you very
much for your question senator
here's a question from jackie very
timely and very interesting question
how does our technology take into
account racial genetic and gender
differences between patients
clinical trials have historically
focused primarily on white males
how can you impact that it's a it's
actually a very good question i don't
have like a perfect answer for that like
these uh
these types of features are included in
our model to to try to modelize that
the fact is and this is a this is an
issue that will
hopefully uh be
reduced in the future as we increase the
the the spectrum of individuals that are
either in the clinic or the
of the data set that we are using for
training of those algorithms
for the moment we have to deal with the
data that we have
so either the public initiatives or the
clinical trials
um to to train those algorithms um
that said uh the there is a various
strategy that you can use more in an
unsupervised way to try to
compensate for these types of bias um
but it's still like it's important that
those
individuals or groups do participate in
either in the clinical trials or in
public initiatives to to really have
a better idea of how these groups do
behave
in reality great point creation thank
you so much
um here's a question from sandeep have
you been approached with having your
foresight solution
in the conduct of a clinical trial with
a master protocol which is a newer
emerging model of clinical study
yet by a sponsor cro or national
collaboration example in oncology
research
so we don't do uh oncology currently
we've focused on more like
broad disease like alzheimer's and now
most recently
in cardiovascular
[Music]
so so i'm not as familiar with these
type of protocols are
trevor are you are you a bit more
familiar maybe
so there's um increasingly especially
we're looking at the importance of
decentralized trials especially since
covid has halted enrollment for a lot
and so
as things are very unevenly reopening
in different parts of the world it it's
very important to have
a collaborative workflow and so um a
benefit to our model is that taking
data from different sources and
different modalities we're able to
integrate it and better understand
patients and
so this as an additional step to a
screening process can really provide
huge benefits um for our
collaborators especially within pharma
and clinicians
um and also please feel free to raise
your hand if you'd like to say something
live
what just out of curiosity on my part um
raise your hand if you are a clinician
i i'm interested to see who has joined
us today
i see a couple great
um and so um with uh the clinicians
present i'm interested to know and
um i'll unmute you and you can feel free
to talk
if um what are some of the problems that
are most pressing to you that you think
comes from a lack of understanding your
patience in a very personalized way
feel free to answer feel free to not and
uh i could definitely have this
discussion with christian as well
i see doug that you're uh yeah you're
one of the attendees i think it's
it would be interesting to have your
your take or your point of view on this
not to put you on the spot yeah so
i mean from you know from my perspective
it's
um you want to know a patient's
prognosis
uh so that you can individualize the
approach to their treatment
you also want to be able to predict if
they're going to respond to a particular
intervention
that's a great point doug christian do
you have
more to say about that i mean i totally
agree uh
this is essentially why those two uh
strategy of uh
of prognosis and uh predictive
enrichments
are are framed for like it's really to
try to pinpoint those those two aspects
that
doug highlighted so so i'm
yeah i don't have anything to do ahead
on that i think it's a
it's a difficult task that definitely
needs careful attention we will
definitely not be able to achieve like
perfection on
on these tasks because there is a lot of
information and components
that are our information that is not
available
to us or to the model when he's doing
his prediction
but i think if we can be better than
chance
uh there is definitely a lot of value
to take into account that the types of
prediction
uh either on the clinical side or on the
clinical trial side
great so here's another question um
building on what dr bengio said
earlier this morning what differentiates
successful and
unsuccessful applications of ai in the
clinical space
yeah it's a good point i think
validation is a critical thing
we need to validate and replicate across
multiple data sets
these types of tools to make sure that
they do generalize
once they are deployed either in the
clinic or in clinical trials
that also link to
the different types of settings where
you acquire the data so if it's imaging
you may have like multiple types of
scanner and variability that
already originated that comes with it
and you need to have ways to
model that at your virginity or at least
be robust to that type of intergenicity
that is not the patient's
rigidity but really more uh acquisition
acquisition scanner or the type of
modalities that
you're acquiring so i think these two
aspects needs to
be carefully validated and replicated to
to be able to have a successful ai
algorithms
uh deployed and this is even more true
in the in the clinic where you have a
much more
broad population of individuals that
will have
uh that may not necessarily correspond
specifically only to the scope
of the clinical trial
great thank you um so here's a question
from uh joseph viviano
how will this platform work with trial
pre-registration
will the predictions of the model be
used when submitting the trial
applications or after the trial is
approved
if so will the regulatory bodies be able
to audit the potential bias in the
predictions of the model when deciding
to approve the trial
so uh we intervene um so it's a good
question so
so we don't the the way we envision this
is to
uh to be during the screening period of
the trial so before randomization
so it's a really clean process during
the clinical trial we don't uh intervene
at all the population that is selected
by the
inclusion exclusion criteria that are
normally done during the trial
plus you can see us or a
prognostic enrichment criteria being
another inclusion criteria or exclusion
criteria
so the the normal framework of a
clinical trial will still be respected
and we don't have any
peak into the after randomization
so basically this is uh this is ongoing
discussion that we have uh
with the fda on um on how they
they want to regulate that but basically
the
whatever criteria that you have uh
inclusion exclusion criteria to
characterize your population that is
investigated
should be tied to the indication of the
drug
and therefore like the if it's an
algorithm or a threshold on
some variables then those things will be
the characteristics of the population
that have been investigated and if the
drug is approved
that's the definition of the population
you should treat
thank you so much um so here's a
question from
nathaniel how large are the populations
we screen
and how rare are the events that we
would detect
uh he asked because in typical
biomarker-based screening efforts rare
events in large populations tend to lead
to over-treatment
many more false positives receive
unnecessary treatment than there are
true positives
receiving benefits
so the depending on the disease the
prevalence will differ
uh individuals and
depending on the stage of the disease
also so in the more
severe phases of alzheimer's
you may have greater than 30 percent of
individuals that will not decline
during the trial sorry less than 30
percent
that will not decline and in mild
cognitive impairment so individuals that
starts to have symptoms that are
not demented yet uh you will have around
30 or even more
of the individuals that will not decline
in cardiovascular it's going to be
around 10 percent of individuals that
will actually have the event that you
decide to
reduce in secondary event and
before that uh before
an initial event then uh those uh
those proportions increase so it really
depends on
uh on the disease obviously like
that's why also we are not taking
extremely rare events like we need
uh we need examples and a
case where there is actually a
substantial amount of individuals that
will have the desirable events
cool thank you um so sandeep has a
question
have you considered medical records
matching ai company pre-fill your list
and then
our platform could produce a highly
qualified patient
uh slash participant list this could
potentially almost eliminate a
recruitment advisor
yeah so so that's that's the intent of
where we want to intervene basically
like you have a first
wave of screening with the inclusion
exclusion criteria
ideally in an automated way apparently
there is a lot of
manual work uh related to identifying
those individuals based on the inclusion
exclusion criteria and then we follow
uh with our analysis uh once you acquire
the
um the relevant biomarkers for those
individuals that fit the inclusion
exclusion the minimal
inclusion exclusion criteria so yeah it
would
potentially be much more automated and
you can source larger database
uh and potentially come up with
candidates that
are more suitable and also faster
great um so here's another one
outside of clinical research where do
you see these approaches being applied
to provide meaningful benefits
uh within patient journeys
well i think the from our experience and
our research in the clinic
it seems that most of the drugs
obviously most of the drugs don't have a
perfect efficacy uh and therefore i
think there is
there is room to use tools like that to
pinpoint a population of responders and
therefore expose
the patient to the the right treatment
and
and prevent others of being exposed to
potential
risk if they don't
have a high likelihood of benefiting
from that treatment
so that's one thing i think maybe trevor
you have some
some ideas more on the on the the
the payers and providers as well
sure so um we're in canada so there is
one payer and it is the
government but in the us there's a
variety of different payer models
many public many private it can include
veterans affairs health care it can
include
medicare which is different in the us
it's it generally means people under a
certain
income level and also uh private insurer
networks that have their own hospitals
and also employer-based insurance so
there's a ton of different models
and so better understanding uh
the relative risk of different patients
and
as uh branching out from that predicting
costs
can have a huge amount of benefits in
both patient
outcomes and also to the payers
themselves
there's a new and increasingly used
paradigm of value-based care which is
reimbursements in the healthcare field
being based
on the quality of care rather than the
amount of conditions which generally
produces better outcomes but also
requires a really good understanding
of relative patient risks and their
outcomes and so
we definitely see a bunch of potential
applications in that field as well
and also eventually in the clinic as
christian said
i think there yeah there is a lot of
room to grow
in in the clinic in various applications
there is
already a few uh a few examples of that
but uh but this is very nascent uh
mason field uh i think we will see a lot
of
emergence of a new newcomers and ways to
optimize
uh response to treatment on of drugs
that are currently on the market
using real world evidence uh i think
that's going to be a
a very interesting wave of a new
solution that will come to the market
in the coming years excellent
and uh this is my question but just
building on that
um where do you see this technology
leading
in the next two years the next five
years and if you have an answer
the next 10 years
um so as i said this is like a very new
field
but i think that as like clear value and
like clear insight that you can derive
from
from such a prognostic information
uh i really think that the the starting
point is clinical trial where like
it's a it's a more rounded and clearer
framework where we can carefully
validate those tools
and then bring them bring them to the to
the market or to the
the clinic once they are approved either
as companion diagnostic or as a tool
that you can use
alongside the the drug or
as an independent tool so i think that's
the first wave is in the clinical trial
setup and then uh much more application
can be derived
uh in the clinic uh with
with uh real world evidence actually
that that will
uh increase another that's also maybe a
point that i didn't cover but most of
these tools
have characterized a certain population
and we can potentially refine those
tools once
once the drug is approved and in phase 4
or
evaluated in the clinic uh it's not like
we
we don't do any study anymore we're
still trying to
monitor uh the drug efficacy
and how it's uh how it's administered
and to which population and i think this
this should be a more dynamic circle
basically we should iterate on that
and and see what's the what's the impact
of the population
being treated and try to refine
[Music]
which population we we want to optimize
for and
identify the subjects either that will
not respond or will not have the
the or the ones that that will respond
great so i think we have time for one
last question if anyone wants to
reach out
you can raise your hands yeah feel free
to raise your hand
um all right well i will ask one last
question so um from your perspective
what are some of the biggest
obstacles that the pharma industry is
facing today and
um uh how can our platform
really alleviate that so i guess that's
really in a nutshell
how are we helping pharma remove these
obstacles
to getting therapies to patients faster
i think yeshua alluded on that earlier
basically uh data is key in these uh in
these types of analysis and
and therefore we need to to to share
the data and try to find ways to uh
[Music]
cut part of the red tape while uh
preserving the the identity of the
individuals that do contribute to that
data
so we need to find ways to
to yeah to better manage that and uh
provide that information so that that we
can actually train uh
competitive models that will have uh
that will be
as less bias as possible um
and and really deliver on accurate
predictions
great thank you so much um so if anyone
has any questions stemming from this
discussion
please don't hesitate to reach out to
either myself or christian and we're
more than happy to connect with you on
linkedin or offline so thank you so much
for attending um
this has been a great discussion thank
you so much for your
excellent presentation christian and
we'll see you at the conference thank
you very much everyone
take care